c'est un projet gigantesque dans le sud
de la france
le programme iter est en train de
prendre forme
cette initiative a été lancée en 2006
par 35 pays dont la france et la russie
objectif reproduire la réaction de
fusion de l'hydrogène qui se produit au
coeur du soleil et des étoiles un plan
ambitieux qui vise à créer une
alternative aux énergies fossiles tout
en évitant les écueils du nucléaire si
la fission de l'atome peut produire des
déchets radioactifs pour des dizaines de
milliers d'années la fusion de
l'hydrogène ne génère pas de déchets de
longvic sur le directeur général d'iter
bernard bigourd une expérimentation qui
fait la fierté des manuels macron iter
c'est une promesse de progrès de
confiance dans la science et c'est
d'ores et déjà une prouesse scientifique
et technologique
imaginez que l'expérience soit
concluante qu'elle puisse trouver demain
des applications industrielles
nous aurons mis au point la une énergie
non polluante décarbonés sur et
pratiquement sans déchets qui permettra
tout à la fois de répondre aux besoins
de toutes les zones du globe de relever
le défi climatique et de préserver les
ressources naturelles
si l'expérience est un succès son
application concrète ne sera pas pour
tout de suite
on estime à 2060 le premier raccordement
au réseau électrique d'un réacteur à
fusion dérivés d'iter un projet plein
d'incertitudes qui fait déjà l'objet de
nombreuses critiques
plusieurs associations écologistes dont
greenpeace y voit un mirage scientifique
est un gouffre financier
non le projet iter n'est pas une
solution pour répondre à l'urgence
climatique
l'idée de fusion nucléaire est aussi
vieille que l'industrie nucléaire
tous les pays qui ont une recherche
nucléaire ont à un moment imaginé ce
type de réacteur miraculeux selon le
calendrier iter les premiers essais
interviendront vers 2025
et si concluant seront suivis de
nouveaux essais dans les décennies qui
suivent
en somme pas de projet de fusion
nucléaire avant 2050
dans le meilleur des cas incompatibles
donc avec l'urgence climatique
des craintes qui peuvent sembler
légitime le programme a déjà pris cinq
ans de retard avec un triplement de son
budget initial à près de 20 milliards
d'euros aujourd'hui